on prime crime how is it possible that a
woman and two kids are just completely
gone
a family disappears and attention shifts
to one man i want her back so bad i want
those kids back so bad
no
yet will the truth ever be known
every time i see pictures i don't know
how this could
[Music]
hi there everybody i'm jesse webber and
welcome to prime crime now this is where
we do a deeper dive into the most high
profile and memorable true crime cases
this episode is about one of the most
gruesome and disturbing events we have
ever covered
in the early morning hours of august 13
2018 a 34 year old woman named shanann
watts returns back to her colorado home
after a business trip
later that day
shenan and her two girls four-year-old
bella and three-year-old celeste would
be reported missing
in this case it was a friend that
reported shanann missing her friend
nicole start to look at the house was
there any evidence of foul play did she
take a suitcase with her was her vehicle
left behind and start putting the pieces
of the puzzle together
shanann was married to 33 year old chris
watts at the time of her disappearance
the family of four was about to get a
bit bigger
the pink is going to be girls i don't
know
just the chest that's awesome
chris and shanann had what would be
considered a picture-perfect marriage
they had a beautiful home they both had
striving careers they had children a
baby that was on the way
we would learn though that shanann and
chris's marriage was on the rocks
we do know that there was some strain in
their marriage there were some issues
with his parents and how they felt about
shanann and shane had expressed in some
text messages to a friend that she felt
that his parents were getting in the way
you start looking at text conversations
and seeing that she was dominant chris
was an introvert shenan was an extrovert
shenan wore the pants in the
relationship and chris was very passive
didn't like any of the public attention
chris tells police that when he returned
from work shenan and the girls were gone
it's at this point when chris's behavior
comes into question
i have no idea like where they went
and it doesn't it's just earth
shattering i don't feel like this is
even real right now it's like a
nightmare that i just can't wake up from
his behavior during the porch interview
was really interesting
he vacillates from being really calm
verbally to being really fidgety and
kind of rocking back and forth
that rocking shows the uneasiness
bella was going to start kindergarten
he talks in the past tense about one of
his daughters the way that he talks
about his children
is as if he's grieving them she's like i
want her back so bad i want those kids
back so bad
um
he kept repeating i just want them back
i just want them back
and there was no real plea for
their safety you know what happened to
them there were no tears there was no
emotion it came out very cool
things get really strange though when
police arrive
wats's neighbor shows the officer and
chris himself what his security camera
picked up in the early morning hours of
the disappearance
the footage never shows shenan leaving
with the girls
instead it reveals chris backing up his
truck into the garage and loading it
before eventually driving away
my water jugs my book bag my computers
some of the tools that i had from the
toolbox i knew i'm gonna have to do some
pumping
pumping into rubbers today
that's why i was out so far
immediately he started offering reasons
as to what he was putting in the vehicle
and he was kind of hyper about that
he's kind of rocking back and forth he's
fidgety his hands are behind his head
these are obvious signs of discomfort
[Applause]
a person who just lost their wife and
children and do not know where they are
would be sitting watching that footage
with their eyes peeled
to the screen to say
let me see if another car came let me
see my wife and children walking out of
the house after i left let me see what
else you picked up
when chris leaves listen to what that
neighbor had to say
he doesn't look
worried
he looks like he's trying to cover his
trap
and if he's loading his stuff why isn't
he walking back and forth
but i can't see what he's doing in the
back of the truck because he's holding
the girl
and he knows my camera's there
he never talks so the fact that he's
over here blabbing his mouth makes me
kind of suspicious
chris was holding a secret from everyone
something that would add a new layer to
this mystery
we're not we're not here to play games
we're not here to do any of that with
you we just want to know what happened
stay with us
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live lawn
crime network with youtube tv for all of
your daily live trial coverage legal
news expert analysis and original true
crime programs subscribe to youtube tv
today and then locate law and crime in
the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle
watch lawn crime every day with youtube
tv we put you in the jury box
how far along
it's august 2018 and law enforcement are
searching for shanann watts and her two
daughters four-year-old bella and
three-year-old celeste the investigation
is now focused on chris watts shanann's
husband and the father of the girls
chris's odd behavior both during media
interviews and while watching
surveillance footage of himself
suspiciously loading his truck on the
day of the disappearance makes some
wonder
is he hiding something
at one point chris is brought in to
speak with investigators
while continually denying having any
knowledge of what happened he does agree
to a polygraph test did you physically
cause shanann's disappearance no
are you lying about the last time you
saw shit in no
the results of that polygraph were not
what watts wanted to hear
so um it is completely clear that you
were not honest during the testing and i
think you already know that
um he did not pass the polygraph test
right okay so now we need to talk about
what actually happened
i didn't i didn't lie to you on that
polygraph i promise
chris i'm i'm first off
obviously there was a lot going on
physiologically with him as he was
answering these questions
to indicate that he was being deceptive
in that moment
he's not a good liar
chris was covering up something
something that he eventually reveals
but you weren't here today lying about
something else
so we need to talk about that okay
about your daughter
thank you
so much for coming out here with me
christopher
i am having a wonderful time
you mean a lot to me
the month prior to shenan and the girls
vanishing chris began a secret affair
with nicole kessinger a woman he met
through work
the affair between chris watts and nikki
kessinger was very quick
he ended up being kind of like a love
sick puppy they had a highly sexual
relationship and it was all-consuming
for chris
she accused me of it i denied it as she
was on her abs so horrible for it like
she was pregnant and he's gotta fell in
love with her
absolutely okay i mean that's god that's
true
despite chris coming clean on the affair
agents coder and lee still don't have an
answer as to the whereabouts of shanann
and the girls and they believe chris
knows more than he's saying
how is it possible that a woman and two
kids are just completely gone on the
face of the earth
i promise you i
i have nothing on my hands
police were using an investigative tool
called the john reed technique initially
what they did is they attempted to be
his friend they came off very soft they
start offering him positive
reinforcement
you're this great guy i'm not just
telling you that okay
we're confused as to why you're not
taking care of your beautiful children
i don't know where they're at
the minute a subject a person starts to
deny
you know what they did the police and
investigator want to cut it off right
away
these are your baby girls
and you have not shed one tear
over them not being around
i love those girls i would never do any
of this because i haven't shed a tear
yeah that's weird is that weird
then what happens is you kind of offer a
how and why like why did this happen how
did this happen
kind of give them an out
chris did shenan do something to them no
i don't know
i'm serious i have no clue
and it's that line of questioning that
leads into the next stage of this
interview
when we return chris's father speaks
with his son and the truth finally
begins to come out
[Music]
get back to your wife and your daughters
okay where are they
that i do not know
that was i was holding back from last
night that's what you feel today
that's not how that works
it's august 15 2018 in colorado chris
watts is telling authorities he has no
idea what happened to his missing wife
shanann and his two daughters
four-year-old bella and three-year-old
celeste who disappeared two days earlier
in fact at the time shenan was pregnant
with the couple's son nico
chris keeps denying having any
involvement in the disappearance despite
failing a polygraph test and admitting
to having an extramarital affair
at one point in his interview with
investigators chris's father ronnie is
brought in to speak with his son
anything else
what's going on
when we had that conversation that
morning it was
it was emotional and
told her about separation and everything
like that
i think bringing his father in to talk
to him was extremely smart on the
investigator's part they were right
there at the edge now you want to offer
that person a sense of comfort
protector
you don't want to protect me
chris shocks his father by claiming that
after getting into an emotional fight
with shanann
she murdered their children
aren't you
i didn't hear anything
all right well
it came back up and
they're gone
talking about separation and everything
about things
he then says he killed her in a fit of
rage
i don't know what else to say
chris explains that after killing
shanann he then decided to transport the
bodies to a site near his workplace
where he proceeded to bury shanann in a
grave and disposed of his daughters in
oil tanks
we hear of moms that kill their kids
usually what precipitates that is some
kind of psychotic break
some extreme substance use or postpartum
and none of these are the case with
shanann this story is not believable at
all it's really convenient for him most
people
would call the police
not
kill their spouse and hide all of the
bodies and try to pretend this never
happened
it's
it's some some of it's hard to believe
that your wife did it right
you can imagine that i don't know okay
the bodies of shenan bella and celeste
would be found by law enforcement at the
work site
chris watts stuck his girls in these oil
drums that were you know eight inches
across
how could somebody do something so
horrific to their own family
you really have to detach yourself and
depersonalize and dehumanize the people
that you're tossing away because you
have to see them as garbage
ultimately authorities didn't believe
chris's version of events and he would
be charged with murdering all three
members of his family
instead of fighting the case
chris pleaded guilty to all charges
as part of that plea deal the government
agreed to take the death penalty off the
table
being in front of people having cameras
and rehashing his bad deeds i think he
wanted to save face and just have it go
away as quickly as possible
but god only knows what happened that
night
life will never be the same without
shannon
ballot and celeste
nico i trusted you to take care of them
not kill them
and they also trusted you
you disgust me
this is
perhaps the most
inhumane
and vicious crime that i have handled
out of the thousands of cases that i
have seen
chris watts was sentenced to five life
terms in prison without the possibility
of parole
this is only half of the chris watts
story
up next there's so much more
couldn't i have like
saved my girl's life couldn't i have
done something why did i do it i don't
know
hi i'm dan abrams in the exploding legal
and true crime genre law and crime is
the only network that has it all good
evening and welcome this is a
complicated case don't really jump to
conclusions welcome to prime crime
tonight another day of drama between
both sides from multiple live trials
daily to original and compelling
programming the long crime network is
everywhere and we invite you inside the
jury box this is law and crime
i think all court shows are the same
we're talking about your father guilty
or not guilty guilty think again judge
caprio rules with common sense i was
having contractions i was rushing to the
hospital inspector quinn what does
justice demand jail
and compassion i'm going to take the
circumstances into consideration the
best court experience i've had clearly
judge he's been in a court before
get caught in providence
[Music]
sounds like a kind of i'm sorry
after coming clean about having an
affair chris watts admitted and pleaded
guilty to murdering his pregnant wife
shanann and their young daughter's
four-year-old bella and three-year-old
celeste he also confessed to disposing
of their bodies in horrific ways his
wife thrown in a shallow grave and his
girls dumped in oil tankers
the story though isn't over
in prison watts agreed to speak with
authorities once again
however this time he divulged new
disturbing details of the killings
i just wish i could have
let go
did it seem like it was that long two to
four minutes i felt like it was longer
almost but like time was standing still
like a snap or something coming out
he chose to kill shanann by
strangulation
and this shows the anger and rage that
he was experiencing in the moment
it makes me believe that there was
probably some big fight that occurred
right before this
and it's also incredibly personal
i don't think he experiences any regret
with shanann
just what happened next
what she said
watts explains that after killing
shanann he loaded her body in his car
along with strapping in his girls who
just sat there with the corpse of their
mother
watts then proceeded to drive out to the
dump site where he claims he then
murdered the girls
cc was
first
i put the blanket
okay
and then went down to bella tell me what
happened man
first yes it was
the same thing
the exact same thing that happened to me
is you see
i don't know if i just said yes like a
horrible person or if i just
put this put that blanket over her too
it did the same thing
but before chris killed bella he claims
she said one last thing
she said no daddy
like every time i closed my eyes i just
hear her saying daddy no and that was it
every day
it's different with the kids
he chose to smother bella in celeste he
is covering their faces
he doesn't see them take their last
breaths there was a bit of him that
didn't want this to happen
that
they were essentially collateral damage
and witnesses to what had happened to
shannon and he needed to remove them
every time i see pictures
chris's account in this interview is a
long way from what he originally told
investigators
the question is is chris now telling the
truth
here's the thing that i found most
peculiar
he was on top of her having this heated
discussion
she like kind of rolled over and i was
just like listening right there on top
of her okay
and then you're talking while you're on
top of her
okay that seems confusing to me
you're in the midst of a breakup and he
said this is when i told her i didn't
love her you wouldn't be straddling your
wife my guts
it was premeditated
making this all the more complicated
while behind bars watts began a
correspondence with an author in a
series of letters watts seems to change
the story once more
what seemed like an unplanned killing of
his daughters
now appears to be premeditated as he
writes in one note
august 12th when i finished putting the
girls to bed i walked away and said
that's the last time i'm going to be
tucking my babies in i knew what was
going to happen the day before and i did
nothing to stop it
i don't believe that he ever intended to
just kill her
and have his kids afterwards because he
separated his life in two boxes he had
this new life of getting an audi looking
for a new place with a new woman having
that sense of freedom and once he had a
taste of that i think that was the point
of no return for him
i think that this was an impulsive act
that was not premeditated and i think
that these letters are an additional
attempt to gain some sympathy and even
empathy from people
while we can debate if chris watts is
actually telling the truth whatever
really happened doesn't change the
impact of this case
nor what it means
back in 2018 i was working in colorado
as a police psychologist assisting law
enforcement in their reactions after
investigating this case and it took a
massive psychological toll on the people
that were involved
people
identified with and were scared of the
fact that this could be
their neighbor that
this seemingly normal happy family of
what you saw on social media was hiding
some very big secrets and this could be
the person that lives three houses down
from you
chris watts went from a beloved father
and husband to one of america's most
infamous killers seemingly overnight
it's a story that is haunting and that
is scary but what is so unsettling about
all this is that as he keeps changing
the narrative and adding details the
reality is
we may never get all the answers that
we're looking for
that's all we have for you here on prime
crime leave us your comments on
instagram and twitter with the hashtag
primecrime as always thank you for
joining us and until next time be safe
[Music]
you